dr ibrahim thanks very much for your
time
um you have become a very strong
advocate uh for
amplifying africa's voice in the global
climate change conversation why are you
so passionate about that why is that so
important you're investing a lot in that
yes because we have a major problem in
africa
in one hand
africans do not put
this stuff up there other people did
people in the north
yet
we have 600 million people in africa 600
that's more than the population
of europe whole population of europe who
don't have access to electricity
can you imagine christine what does it
mean
to live without electricity
can you have a business can you have a
factory can
can you have a life can you have
hospitals can i have education
we cannot talk even about development
people living in like a stone age
half of our population those people
usually need energy
yet
we have the climate crisis and our good
system we're trying also to do what we
can
so many countries in africa
are actually using
renewable energy
it is almost a secret nobody knows this
but you know that 22 african countries
22
rely completely almost completely on
renewal
renewable is the main source of
electricity for 22
african countries no european
or any other continent can compare with
that so we're doing our best
but
renewables are not enough
we need to have a mix
we need also to
need gas
okay
and that's bringing me to my next
question because
we have these global climate goals that
have been set at the last climate change
summit cop 26 a decision was taken to
stop investing in gas infrastructure for
example you're talking about an energy
mix where we in africa because we have
this huge gap
need to invest in energy projects
we've heard no
so what does that mean for us
it is it is it is christine i'm gonna be
frank i hope i don't upset anybody it is
crazy is the most stupid decision
i heard you have after the decision
of putin to unveil
ukraine
these are the most too stupid decisions
over the last year
now
europe
is wallowing in gas
germany
use a lot of gas
russian gas
actually half of african gas is
exported to europe
and
they don't have 600 million people
without power and people say no no no
you cannot you cannot you cannot use
guys here
this is morally bankrupt
is is just that's immoral
right and
is this european value we were told that
european project
built around values
is this
part of european values
i don't think so
and it was a wrong decision and people
should have the honesty and the
integrity to stand up and say
sorry we made a mistake
now
the chancellor of of germany was in a
senegal
seeking
gas
he was
in qatar
trying to get gas
is that the same country we say so
africa no no no you cannot have gas
it doesn't doesn't work like that right
governance i think ties in very well
with the next question because
we have the minerals we have the
resources that the world needs
to build a more sustainable future right
to power the electric vehicles that
we're not burning fossil fuels
but how do we
manage these resources
well and better as africans better than
we've done with oil and diamonds for
example
so that it benefits
everybody
especially people in africa that is a
real challenge christine
because we have totally totally
mismanaged our resources
whether material
resources or human resources
and
people coined an expression the
resource cares
because
look at what happened in congo and other
countries with
with resources
total abuse
corruption uh people did not benefit
from the value i single out botswana i
mean i look at the botswana model
where a country manages its resources
well
all the leaders there have clean hands
every bin is accounted for negotiated
the right deal
with
with with with
the the the
companies
uh which
they contracted with them
disappear in this case
uh and use all that to move the country
forward that is great unfortunately
that's not happening in many of our
countries
so how then can africa's interests be
better included in this global climate
change conversation the problem
christine is africa has no voice
when those guys came to glasgow and
talked about finance there was no way
for africans excuse me do you realize
this is the facts about africa
the people that have had to think about
it before the rush we don't have a voice
and one of the objectives of our
conference
uh which we have in here
this week in london
was really to try and develop
a coherent case
for africa because the next cup will be
held in africa
and it will be a shame if we host
the cop 27 without presenting the case
for africa
and that should be really presented in a
coherent
uh manner to the international community
for people to understand what the
challenge you're facing right you spend
a lot of time with our leaders on the
african continent
as you do leaders in europe and other
parts of the world
are african leaders taking the issue of
climate change seriously from where you
sit
i wish you were aware
i wish
also to be an emphatic yes
some of them do
and some unfortunately don't
it's a nature of situation i mean
we have a number of fragile countries
who have some countries
suffering from military crews i mean my
own country in sudan
we have those crazy generals and taken
off by all validation just take of power
powerful sacred power and money of
course
uh do you think those guys think from a
moment
about climate change or about
they don't think about what's good for
their own people do you think what
they're going to think about what's good
for the whole
the whole world unfortunately not it's
sad
because
we are fighting really for a better
leadership in africa some of our leaders
are doing wonderful i mean yesterday i
had a great
interview with uh makisel who is
the chair of the african union and the
man is running around really trying
to fight the case for
africa and
he led the discussion
in the last
africa europe summit in brussels when we
had a very robust discussion there
about the issue of energy and
the case was put in a competent way
during that meeting and that's what
trying to articulate to get all africa
behind that so we can really put our
case forward let's talk about what's
going on right now
in ukraine you alluded to that
earlier in our conversation
i've heard a lot of criticism about how
all the focus is turning to this war
much to the negligence of what's going
on in other parts of the world
in africa we're going to feel the impact
of this war in ukraine we're seeing it
already
food prices
and inflation increasing partly due to
other factors but exacerbated now
by by this war in ukraine
but i am surprised to see so many
african leaders choosing to be neutral
choosing not to condemn russia uh for
for its invasion of ukraine what do you
make of that
right let us
start with facts majority of african
countries condemned
some countries
abstained
some countries did not even show up to
vote
but the majority of those who didn't
condemn
our african country no no
27 countries
voted for the u.s out of 54 yeah 28 or
something the majority voted against
the invasion condemned the invasion
and the best speech actually
made at the assembly was a kenyan speech
remember what the
kenyan ambassador speech was always a
wonderful powerful speech about respect
for borders and sovereignty
so that that was
now
some of the countries which
[Music]
did not participate
mind you only one country supported
russia
only one country eritrea and we know
what the situation was earth here as a
country in a way
but you have to remember in some of our
countries which are ruled by the
military
and
there is a close link between the
military and russia
russia
is the largest armed
trader in africa
50 percent
of the
arms
procured by africans comes from russia
and when you have some generals running
a country you know where this allegiance
they want to maintain
their
hardware and stuff and that's
their supplier
[Music]
some countries also rely
on their foot
you know
on russia and
so there is that some kind of influence
some
few countries had some romantic
association
with the soviet union
because of the support of soviet union
to those
leaders of movement during the
liberation struggle
and they think they owe a debt to the
soviet union
and this confusion between the soviet
union and russians russia very different
things different but there is confusion
and they say oh this is the same russian
guys anyway so there is this some
confusion
and
we should not undermine also
underestimate what the russian efforts
in africa cesaro wagner group is playing
around
uh in
in russia i mean
in in africa they are in cr
and they are in
mali and
so
the military link and the military board
is
playing but that also is a message to
our friends in europe and our american
friends etc
guys you need to work a little bit
harder to win people you just don't sit
back
and
then also there are some voices
or some people who are worried about
hypocrisy
hypocrisy because
people see also that
[Music]
we have an illegal war here
in ukraine a country invades another
country
with whatever fictitious reasons
but you say
but didn't u.s
invade iraq
and with that
illegitimate war they haven't got
authorization from united nations
did not bother and then
they claimed this weapon of mass
destruction which is not true
they're not happy with that
then you have situation of libya
you know
us and some european countries
when their change helped change the
regime
dumped huge amount of arms
to unknown
entities
and we ended up now with a broken
country
with huge amount of arms
in the sahara which many of that is used
by terrorism now
and with that right action
what i'm trying to say here it is
important for the west also
to always live up to its value
because people watch and see
and don't accept hypocrisy
and
that that that we should avoid
uh
that and when we make mistakes who stand
up and own it
i want to end off with something that uh
senegal's president mikey sull said to
you at this forum in in your interview
with him he called
for sanctions on russia to be partially
lifted to allow
for
fertilizer from russia
to be exported so as to avoid a famine
as he put it
that's really controversial
because right now the message is
punished russia starved russia of its
ability to be able to continue its
aggression
let me
okay
again i'll talk about hypocrisy
how much germany
pays russia today monthly for gas
hundreds of millions huge
amount of money who is financing now
the russian war machine
is germany
correct
this is facts
and i said at the beginning i hope
people don't get upset but we need to
ask we cannot be friends if we cannot be
frank with each other
okay
now
africans say
you did not impose sanctions on gas
because you think you need gas imported
for your economy
now i need food here i have a famine
i'm not talking about the environment in
order to have a nice living with
electric
to eat we don't have food can you please
remove sanctions on food
why that is controversial
when you refuse
to put sanctions on gas
christine that what to always say
i love the west i love democracy i love
the ideal and the values and that's why
i live here because i love these values
but guys please live up your values
don't betray your own values
and before you throw stones or people
you maybe your house is made of glass
so if anybody tells you that removing
sanctions on food
to avert or to stop famines
is immoral
ask him about the amount of money paying
for gas
exactly yeah
dr ibrahim
thanks so much for your time thank you